Justin you've made now two features that
have both received distribution do you
have any information that most
filmmakers don't have on securing a
distribution deal do you have any tips I
wish I did I think the one for an
independent film getting in front of an
audience and getting it reviewed by some
of the tastemakers and I think the best
tunnel for that to happen is through
through going to festivals and film
festivals so if you want to go back to
before I made features I made short
films and my final short film that I
made at UCLA film school got to play
festivals all over the country and I
made relationships with festivals that
way so that when I had a future I was a
known quantity or at least a more known
quantity than say someone who didn't
have any connections in the or or
relationships in the film festival world
that said the film festivals select the
films based on whether they liked you
not whether they like you but whether
they liked the film it just does help
though to get it in front of the right
decision makers sometimes if you know
them already which is not to say that it
gets you in but it gives you a better
chance because you know that if you have
spent a year or two years playing film
festivals with a short film they
recognize your name and then you can
contact them and say hey just just in
case you miss it try to look for this
movie then you have an advocate at that
film festival I'm not I'm not saying
that that's the only thing that but that
makes makes it you got in but it does
help because there's just every year
more and more films being made anything
that you can do to put your film on the
top of the stack of the ones they need
to watch is obviously to your advantage
as far as distribution goes I'm hopeful
that there's more festivals every year
where people will be buying films but
right now at you know in the United
States there's very few there's Sundance
there's you if you count Toronto North
America
and then there's South by Southwest
Tribeca maybe even Los Angeles Film
Festival I hope that every year it will
grow the number of festivals where films
are bought and and put into distribution
because that only helps the independent
filmmaker to have more options of places
to premiere their movie so I'm hopeful
that every year there's more but that
that is really the way that that I think
right now the system and the industry
facilitates a distributor that and good
reviews so going back to the festival
circuit if someone can't let's say
travel with the film how would you
recommend that they still sort of like
keep a relationship with that festival
cuz you know they might have other
obligations you know a job it won't give
them time off or something right so is
there other ways that they can keep sort
of their name good with that festival
well I mean if your film is playing at
that festival you know find out who
programmed it to send them a thank-you
note I don't think there's anything that
prohibiting you from calling up the
festival and just saying like sorry I
can't be there just having a
relationship obviously being at the
festival and meeting someone in person
is the best opportunity to foster a
relationship but there are other ways
there's plenty of festivals in my run
with my short film that I wasn't able to
go to but you know the fact that they're
playing it is a good opportunity for you
to reach out and keep a little you know
address book full of the people that are
your supporters one of my mentors when I
was at UCLA film school
always gave us the advice to make sure
you go to the people that love you and
and the people who have been supporting
you and if there's a Film Fest two
festivals competing for your movie one
they're both good ones maybe one's a
little better ones a little bit less big
but the one that's a little less big has
been writing you in calling you saying
we really want to premiere a movie the
bigger one is saying yeah
a be able to program you just wait and
see like we've got a whole bunch of
other ones we got to look through but
this other one that's almost as good is
is just beating down your door for it
there is an argument to be had about
going to the one that really is passion
about you because they're going to
program you on the best nights they're
gonna internally promote your film
they're gonna put a still of your film
on the catalog they're going to make
sure everyone and their audience knows
about your film I'm not saying this
would work every time you might want to
hold out for the bigger one because it's
that much bigger but sometimes it is in
the and in the filmmakers benefit to
really go find your champions and make
sure that you remain connected with them
there's a film festival that I love in
Northern California Mill Valley Film
Festival they were such big fans of my
first feature that I was able to stay in
touch with them and then when it came
time to vote for the Gotham award we got
nominated for a Gotham Award and it was
the only award that year that was
decided by audience members online who
would vote Mill Valley Film Festival was
integral in sending out the link that
IFP sent out to all of their community
who saw the film during the festival to
vote for it and we won the Gotham Award
in no small part thanks to the festival
that I had remained in contact with over
the course of the year our is Mill
Valley a festival that is a market where
things are bought know is it a really
beautiful amazingly curated festival
with great films and wonderful people
yeah so it's not a Sundance Tribeca
Telluride South by Southwest where you
know films are premiered and and bought
but it's on that next tier of great
festivals and if you stay in touch with
those places they will support your work
especially if you decide
to bring it there and in the independent
film world you can never have too many
advocates because they're few and far
between usually so it's about really
finding those places that love you and
making sure you maintain a good
relationship with them because they
probably very much want to see you
succeed because your success is their
success because they took a chance on
you by programming your movie just and I
believe before you've said that you
liked to explore taboos and your films
but without beating the audience over
the head so to speak moment those are my
words forcing them to feel a certain way
can you talk about when you set up a
scene how it would be set up to force
someone to see something versus letting
them sort of discover and feel their own
way about it I think first and foremost
leaving enough space in a scene or in a
film for the audience to put some of
themselves or or their own ideas into
the films so whether that's leaving a
scene ambiguous leaving certain things
unsaid and just rely on the visuals
rather than on the spoken word ending a
scene early before we know how it
logically concluded I'm a big fan of
taking what the movies about and not
having it in the direct dialogue but
having it be implied through the
situation also creating a very difficult
and maybe enigmatic and/or ambiguous
situation between two people that I
refuse to resolve and almost allow two
or three different opportunities to it
for it to be resolved and I don't tell
the audience which one it is the film
the automatic Kate actually ends in a
very ambiguous way where we know it's
either one thing or the other thing that
happened but I kind of leave it to the
audience to decide which one I feel as
long as I give a very specific rendering
of what those two options are I don't
need to answer it because I think that
being able to think of the specific
options and having that decision to make
is specific enough so when I guess you
think about people beating you over the
head I think it's when one thing happens
and the audience feels without a doubt
one way about it there's no room for the
audience to feel differently because the
text the image and the the material is
telling the audience this is how you
should be feeling right now
whereas I allow a little more space to
say here's what's happening but I'd like
you to decide for yourself how you feel
some of that can be done with the way
it's shot some of that can be done with
not having a lot of dialogue tell you
what the morals are or the the lesson
there are no lessons I think in good
storytelling and then music you know
sometimes the music beat you over the
head in the sense of like the music
makes you feel the way that it tries to
describe what you're seeing and if music
can be used that not not to close you
off and say here is sad music for a sad
scene or exciting music for like an
action scene but just to allow the film
to open up for for more room to think
and space to think it's not beating you
over the head so to speak
it's it's providing them a bigger room
to walk around in and and figure out
what you feel about what you're seeing
so in my films I'll present characters
who are very specific in what they're
doing but they're they're acting in very
morally kind of gray areas they're doing
possibly they're possibly they're nice
people possibly they're they're
relatable people and possibly they're
they're charming people but they are
doing things that are maybe a little bit
quote-unquote immoral or wrong or or
complicated morally and instead of
telling you how to feel about that I'd
rather just present you with that
messiness and allow an audience to kind
of decide for themselves how they feel
and I feel like that's something that
requires out into be a little bit more
active but at least I'm not I
telling an audience how they should feel
about anything in any particular moment
they undoubtedly will feel a certain way
it's just I don't feel it's like my job
to tell them that's the way and whatever
their reaction is is the correct one
because it's how they're feeling Justin
in the automatic hate with your two
characters
aside from Alexis's beauty why is Davis
so drawn to her it's a good question
it's something that I wrestled with with
catherine o'brien a lot because we
didn't want to reduce the character to
just this object of desire right if you
look at what the movies really about and
in my mind while it's about a man a
young man finding out that he has this
family that he didn't know about that
his father has hidden from him it's a
lot about fidelity and faithfulness and
you know wondering what else is out
there other than the person he's
committed to a big theme in the movie
that Catherine and I wanted to really
explore was the idea of the difference
between the city and the countryside or
civilization and the wilderness right
you have one side of the family Davis
and his father and his mother college
professors and his girlfriend who
believe in civilization they pay their
parking tickets they they they obey the
law they vote on time they send in their
electricity bill on time right they they
are faithful to each other they try not
to lie cheat and steal they try not to
get angry at people and then you have
his uncle Josh and his aunt Sarah and
all and look and the wild cousins who
live in the woods of upstate New York
they're in the wilderness and they
believe in eating what you want to eat
screaming at who you wanted to scream
with sleeping with who you want to sleep
with punching who you want to punch they
believe in the allowing yourself to
indulge in whatever desire you have at
the moment all all action zero for
thought whereas his parents are all like
the product of man-made rules in a
civilization with sidewalks parking
spaces walls ceilings
and Davis while he is in that world with
his parents and his girlfriend goes to
meet the other side of the family and
sees that he has a lot in common with
them too even though he lives a very
yuppie urban kind of law-abiding
lifestyle he's a chef so there's a
little bit more in there about indulging
in the pleasure of the senses right so
there is a piece of him that is
attracted to the lifestyle of giving in
to what you want to do and not being
ashamed of those desires just like his
uncle did and has defined his whole life
by living by choice out in the
wilderness where there is no
civilization breathing down his neck
telling him where he can park his car
and who he can scream at and he can't
spit on the ground he can do all of that
stuff so in a way alexis is a reminder
that there is another way to live your
life that is counter to what
civilization says you should and should
not do and in a way it's inside of him
already
alexis is just there to almost wake it
up and in a sense yes she's very
beautiful and yes she's very fun and yes
she's very carefree and there's some but
there's something that is inside of
Davis that almost feels trapped that she
brings out whereas he's trapped by a
girlfriend who even though he loves her
is a little bit overbearing parents who
are very judgmental and don't really see
or even approve of his lifestyle they
much prefer him to be a professor like
them and think that his uh they even go
so far as to call his little tenure as a
chef as a little hobby right so alexis
is not just a beautiful girl that comes
to that that he's attracted to
she's a ticket out of the overbearing
unbelievably parochial lifestyle that he
has right now she's she's a window into
the other side of the the hills that he
can go play and dance and
a little while and maybe for a little
too long and it gets a little too
dangerous
just to indulging too much in that
lifestyle obviously brings him to some
pretty extreme places in this film but
it's just the idea of there are other
places maybe it's a grass is always
greener but alexis is beautiful but
she's also an invitation to going out
into that other side of of civilization
that anti civilization right that he's
never been a part of but kind of
desperately wants to try out so without
giving away a lot of the things in the
automatic Kate because you you do keep
the audience wondering and you it is
very subtle in terms of crafting the
story in this surprise ending what was
the process like I mean did you know
from the beginning how you wanted it to
turn out or as you were writing it did
it sort of evolve the secret I have to
say my writing partner who wrote the
film with me Catherine O'Brien and I
decided something terrible happened to
split the family up but we actually
decided it as we were writing and when
we got to the scene we stopped and we
thought for a couple days on what it was
and then it became clear to us that it
needed to relate without giving anything
away he needed to relate to the rest of
the story whatever happened between
those two dads those brothers their kids
would have to discover it and it had to
send reverberations through the family
and so we decided it couldn't be
something just strange and as a one-off
like tragedy or something we needed it
to be about what was going on between
the cousins and so we decided to tie it
all in together but we did not know as
we were writing the first two acts what
happened but we knew was bad enough that
it would have to be we would have to
have earned the fact that these brothers
haven't spoken for 30 years so that's
how it evolved and then obviously you go
back this was in the first draft I mean
once you decide you go back and rewrite
and rewrite and rewrite and with that
decided already
but yes in the first draft we were just
like we'll decide what happened when we
get to that scene
and I know Justin as we set up here you
said something in passing that was
interesting to me as a filmmaker and
you've done now two features and
previous short films you've gone to film
school you don't actually own a DSLR and
you don't own a filmmaking camera you
own a film 35 mil i I don't own one
digital the only digital camera I own is
my my cell phone I and I have a 35
millimeter still camera that I used very
rarely I don't think the tool makes you
a filmmaker I think the yeah though your
mind and your your the way you see the
world makes you a filmmaker not to say I
wouldn't if someone wanted to someone
wanted to give me a beautiful DSLR
camera I would love one
it's just that I don't own one because I
whatever technology is available at the
time I'm making the film and it changes
so rapidly that I'm not a filmmaker
that's going to invest in a camera to
then make my own films the production
will get the best camera and my
cinematographer who have worked with now
on both of my feature films she will
decide what the film needs to be shot on
with me as an adviser but she's going to
do it so we shot my first feature on the
red when the red was a thing and then it
was you know three and a half four years
before we started shooting the automatic
hate and by that point the Arriflex
Alexa was just really affordable and
really great and my cinematographers
mentor swore by the camera so that's
what we shot Ben and who knows on the
next one that I'm preparing now who
knows what we shoot on but I don't
believe that that a filmmaker needs to
own a camera or even care about that in
order to be a filmmaker because the tool
changes quickly you know and it will
change until you're done being a
filmmaker so I I'm more a fan of
whatever is the best at the moment that
you're shooting yeah what about apps or
other technology anything that's sort of
your ear real in love with right now in
terms of apps whether it's something
that organizes your day
no no nothing no I I still write all my
to dues for the day in the week with pen
on a loose-leaf piece of paper or a
moleskin I like mole skins there there
so and graph paper well does that date
me or make me a dinosaur I don't know I
just I feel like if all of your
appointments and all of your schedules
are in some device that if you lose it
it's gone or or I I don't I mean I know
it could be backed up on some cloud or
something like that but even that to me
feels ephemeral I like this might tell a
lot about me I I like reading books and
taking a pen and writing notes in the
margins I don't own any ebooks I print
scripts out when my friends want me to
read them and I mark them with pen and I
deliver them to them I may be a dying
breed but it feels more real that way so
yeah do you like the tactile experience
yeah yeah if you believe in astrology it
is said that the year I the the month I
was born is only into things that they
can see and touch the tactile experience
of nice looking and nice smelling and
nice touching nice feeling things I'm a
Taurus if that is okay I don't know how
I feel about astrology but I've been
told that Tauruses are into the
pleasures of the senses of being able to
touch things and see things in real
space yeah right interesting and you
have you're very pragmatic and stubborn
and opinionated and passionate uh-huh
that's most people yeah
sometimes too stubborn and opinionated
for my own good I think well I think all
of us have that in us but what are you
grappling with in terms of your current
state of creativity whether it's getting
a production together I mean we wanted
to put that out to our audience because
people that watch our videos are also
filmmakers and screenwriters and actors
and we're just curious what's something
in 2016 that's troubling you or is is
posing a challenge
creativity-wise on a day to day level
one of the biggest challenges I have is
finding hours in the day to write you're
if you look at your day if you say okay
well you know health is very important
for me in longevity and and staying in
good health because energy especially
when you're getting ready to go shoot a
movie you know you live and die by your
health and how being able to get up
every day so I put into my morning an
hour of working out and then I have just
because I'm I have OCD a half an hour to
cleaning the apartment and just
arranging everything in the apartment so
that there's nothing you know wrong and
you know my girlfriend's more of a
disheveled artist who her clothes are
always so I I'm the tidier one so I
clean up her stuff too and then that's
another half an hour of the day I like I
like to cook and I like you know not not
only for saving money but also just the
idea of you know for health reasons just
being able to know what's in my food and
so most mornings I will cook myself food
there's another half an hour and then
cleaning up another good and it's like
it eats up your day and then you've got
like 15 emails 20 emails 30 emails to
respond to there's an hour of your
morning you want to get a coffee and
then whatever else you have in the day
and then by the time you you blink
before you know it it's noon and you
know a million things going on whatever
it is that day whether you have a
meeting or something to get to somebody
so it's it's protecting as you get older
and have more responsibilities whether
it's your routine in the morning whether
it's your OCD cleaning or just the way
that you maintain your health and your
rituals to stay healthy in the morning
outside of your work or it's your actual
work or it's a combination of all of
that plus like you know paying your
bills and making sure the apartment is
is locked up and and and cleaned
whatever it is that you're doing it adds
up to like leave you maybe a couple
hours a day whether it's in the night
when all the emails and phone calls are
stopped or in the morning before
anything starts happening
it's those protecting those precious
hours where you can actually put
everything out of your mind and just
concentrate on whatever you're doing for
me I'm a writer-director so a lot of
times nothing happens until I've you
know put in the creative work to make
the next project go that can also be on
noting something it could also be on
revising it could also be on writing a
compelling email to an actor in order to
get them interested in your part it
doesn't have to be just writing a script
but finding the time to do that becomes
more challenging as you get older also
whatever job I have to be doing in the
meantime to make extra money I I just
directed a short film for hire that is
going to be coming out I hope this year
but my responsibilities for that film
have taken up many hours of the day too
I've written for hire for other people
other people's scripts and done polishes
and rewrites all of this adds up to
taking hours out of your day and it's
just the biggest challenge for me is
finding that on the small level on a
bigger level finding money for your film
finding an audience for your movie
that's already been made those are
struggles that I'm not and I think every
indie filmmaker has yeah